[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم تواصلوا الغارات
الاسرائيليه على غزه ارتفاع عدد الشهداء
الى اكثر من 25 بينهم سته اطفال وجيش
الاحتلال يقول انه تم اطلاق 500 وسبعه
صواريخ من قطاع غزه ويعلن قصف 147 هدفا في
القطاع منذ بدء عمليته العسكريه في
الاثناء اكدت كتائبه سرايا القدس استشهاده
قيادييها علي غالي واحمد ابو دقه لديني
استهدفا بقصف اسرائيلي على خان يونس
اتصالات دوليه لوقف التصعيد في غزه وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي طلب من نظيره الاسرائيلي
العمل على وقف التصعيد ومصادر تقول
للجزيره ان اسرائيل ارسلت عبر مصر رساله
بان وقف اطلاق النار يعني وقف الاغتيالات
دون تقديم ضمانات
بالتزامن مع الذكرى السنويه الاولى
لاغتيال الزميله شيرين ابو عاقله اداره
شبكه الجزيره تجدد تعهدها لعائله شيرين
وزملائها بانها لن تدخر جهدا لتحقيق
العداله ومحاسبه القتله واكده انها ستتابع
قضيتها التي رفعتها الى المدعي العام
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في لاهاي
رئيس حزب البلد التركي محرم انجي يعلن
انسحابه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه قبل ثلاثه
ايام من الاقتراع مشيرا الى ان اعلانه
الانسحاب لكي لا يتم لومه عندما يخسر
الطرف الاخر في الانتخابات في اشاره الى
تحالف الشعب المعارض ومرشحه كمال كلتشدار
اوغلو
الى اللقاء